[Musique]
la troisième édition du salon des
seniors s'est déroulée à saint denis
un rendez vous entièrement dédié aux 50
ans et plus qui pendant trois jours ont
pu rencontrer plus d'une centaine
d'experts spécialisés dans le bien-être
chef de file de la prise en charge des
personnes âgées à la réunion le
département tenait un stand
d'information sur ces dispositifs
département propose deux aides légales
pour le personnes pour les personnes
âgées
donc la paix à l'allocation
personnalisée d'autonomie et l'aide
ménagère légal donc pour les personnes
âgées de plus de 60 ans et en aides
facultatives nous avons l'aide ménagère
facultatif et du cou
c'est pour les personnes âgées de plus
de 60 ans également mais qui dépasse le
plafond de la légal voilà en sinon
le département a mis également en place
dot notre aide
le pass loisirs ou le pass transport
avec les jets en écho entendu on a fait
un point en charge des personnes âgées
on n'est pas tout seul et si à la
réunion avec 92 millions d'euros de
budget consacré aux personnes âgées
le département est un acteur
incontournable dans leur prise en charge
et le bien vieillir en 2012
sous l'impulsion de la collectivité et
crée la spl à venir réunion sa mission
première est d'oeuvrer à l'amélioration
de l'habitat pour les familles les plus
modestes
quand une une personne que j'ai à nous
voir pour faire une demande d'adp à
l'action dans l'habitat donc la spl va
vérifier son éligibilité par rapport à
ses revenus par rapport à sa composition
familiale par rapport à sa condition
sociale et on va déterminer donc les
travaux qui sont éligibles est
prioritaire et suite à cela donc une
subvention sera demandée auprès du
département
si le département a validé la subvention
les travaux seront réalisés est suivi
par l'espère une spl récompensée par le
premier prix du bien vieillir à la
réunion une reconnaissance pour son
engagement dans le développement de sa
qualité de service et ses innovations
pour l'amélioration du bien vieillir à
la réunion en 2017 a été près de 900
dossiers d'amélioration de l'habitat et
le envisageons de passer à 1000 dossiers
cette année mais ce qui est important
c'est de savoir pour espérer et dans la
réactivité
elle sait gérer des situations d'urgence
parce que nous avons mis en place une
régie et cette régie permet ben
justement de travailler rapidement pour
apporter une réponse à des besoins
urgents faveur des personnes âgées
et puis je voudrais vous dis aussi que
l'espérer a développé un outil
qui permet à tout le monde de constituer
son dossier d'amélioration de l'habitat
sans avoir à se déplacer une plateforme
numérique
bien sûr et utilisable par les familles
à nos gramounes pour constituer leur
dossier d'amélioration de l'habitat
[Musique]